guillermo del toro brought us the
visually stunning kg fight fest that was
Pacific Rim if giant fighting robots and
monsters from another dimension wasn't
enough the film now requires inspiration
from dinosaurs and blind crime fighters
I'm Simon and this is your giant monster
news update while Guillermo del Toro
remains on board as executive producer
of Pacific Rim to his involvement in the
sequel is somewhat reduced earlier this
year it was announced that former
daredevil showrunner Steven denied would
direct and now it has been reported that
Jurassic world Derek Connolly is to
write the script according to The
Hollywood Reporter Connolly is the
latest writer to join the film del Toro
himself has written 1 draft with zak
penn and john Speights also contributing
it is unknown whether Connelly will be
rewriting the script from scratch or
working from an existing draft Connelly
is one of the Hollywood's most in-demand
screenwriters his other upcoming credits
include Kong Scott Island and Star Wars
Episode nine the Knights directora was
announced in February the status of
pacific rim 2 has changed over the past
few months with various press stories
and it disappearance from release
schedules suggesting that the movie was
far from a sure thing however del Toro
has always insisted that the project is
moving ahead in January legendary
pictures was bought by chinese
conglomerate dalian wanda group for a
massive 3.5 billion dollars although the
domestic gross for the first Pacific Rim
was disappointing in China it proved
extremely popular it opened with the 6
biggest gross ever for a Hollywood movie
and ultimately earned more than a third
of its entire international growth in
China are you excited for more kaiju
combat let me know in the comments or
come find me on Twitter i'm at the jagan
or thanks for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot
Oh